if the transformation matrix T is equal
to three zero zero three choose which
sketch can represent this transformation
when applied to the red quadrilateral
this is fascinating so they don't give
us any any coordinates a for the
vertices of the quadrilateral which are
really the most useful points to use
when thinking thinking about potential
transformations so just let's just make
up some just to see what would happen to
the particular coordinates that we're
looking at and I think that will give us
enough information to think about this
and I encourage you to do it on your own
first pause the video come up with some
coordinates for this for this for this
red quadrilateral and then see what
transformation you get in which of these
seem to be closest to the one that that
you got so I'm assuming you've had a go
at it
and let's just say for the sake of
argument that this point right over here
that right there you could say that's
the position vector I'll represent it as
a column vector let's say that is let's
say this is a square and so this is one
comma one so I'll just write that as the
column vector as a column vector 1 1 and
let's say this one then would be this is
this one right over here would be 1
negative 1 1 negative 1 and then this
one over here would be this point right
over here could be represented by the
position vector negative 1 negative 1
negative 1 negative 1 negative 1
negative 1 and then finally finally this
point right over here could be
represented by the position vector
negative 1 1 negative 1 1 so let's see
what the transformation matrix would do
when it transforms these four points and
the way I'm going to think about it let
me just take our transformation matrix
so 3 0 0 3 and I'm going to multiply it
by a 2 by 4 matrix that multiple that
represents all of these position vectors
so I'm going to multiply it by so we
have this point 1 1 that's our first
point we have the point 1 negative 1 1
negative one we have this point which is
negative 1 1 negative 1 1 and then we
have this point which is negative 1
negative 1 negative 1 negative 1 and
that these were convenient points to
pick since it didn't give us the points
because it'll make the math fairly
straightforward so what is this going to
be equal to we have a 2 by 2 2 by 2
times a 2 by 4 matrix multiplication is
defined here because we have the same
number of columns as we have rows right
over here and we're going this is going
to result in a 2 by 4 matrix so this is
going to give us another 2 by 4 matrix
which makes sense because we're going to
need 4 column vectors here for our four
new transformed points and let's figure
out what it is so the first the first
column vector right over here we could
think about this row in this column so
or exit the first position right over
here this first row first entries this
row this column the second one's going
to be this row the second row in the
first column so let's see 3 times 1 plus
0 times 1 well that's 3 plus 0 so this
is going to be 3 and then over here 0
times 1 plus 3 times 1 is going to give
us 3 as well I think you see already a
pattern here is that when you multiple I
guess you could say the x coordinate for
each of these vectors we're involving
this row and this row we really just
multiply it
we just we really just multiply the 3
times the x coordinate here and then we
don't involve the y coordinate because
we're multiplying it times 0 we'll see
that over and over again so over here
you have 3 times 1 3 times 1 plus 0
times negative 1 so it's just really 3
times 1 which is 3 and then over here
you see this for the y coordinate each
time we're only involving the y
coordinate of the of the of the point
before transformation you see 0 times 1
is 0 so we're essentially not thinking
about the x coordinate and then it's
just 3 times negative 1 which is
negative 3 so you see what it's just
doing is it's just it's just scaling
each of these up by a factor of 3
or three times zero times three times
negative one is negative three plus zero
times one so it's negative three and
then it's going to be zero times
negative one zero plus three times one
is three and then finally 3 times
negative 1 is 3 times negative one plus
zero times negative one is negative
three and then zero times negative one
plus three times negative one is
negative three again so what's going to
happen to it well each of these
coordinates essentially get pushed out
by a factor of three so actually this
one seems to be the closest to the one
that we're thinking about how do I know
that well look at this this this is the
point this is the point one comma one
right over there
so one comma one and it gets mapped to
the point 3 comma 3 so 1 2 3 1 2 3 this
is 3 comma 3 right over there this got
mapped to that and we see it with each
of them 1 negative 1 1 negative 1 gets
mapped to 3 negative 3 and then we have
negative 3 or sorry we have negative 1 1
negative 1 1 negative 1 1 is getting
mapped to negative 3 3 and then finally
of course negative 1 negative 1 negative
1 negative 1 gets mapped to negative 3
negative 3 so it's definitely the second
the second diagram is the one that
represents what what hat wasn't that
what that represents the transformation
matrix T being applied to the red
quadrilateral